so at the School of Life we're really
interested in emotional health and
emotional well-being and on this channel
you'll have seen loads of films around
how to live wisely how to approach the
challenges of everyday life now there's
one person when we set up the school of
life there was always one person at the
back of my mind he's my hero he's I've
met lots of people in my life but
there's really only one that I'm
desperate and longing to me and I've
been telling all my friends for years
that this is one man who actually lives
in the same city as I living in London
same part of London even that I want to
meet more than any other because what
he's done is what we're trying to do
with the school of life he's taken a
subject which is quite arcane which was
seen only for specialists and which is
actually absolutely vital to well being
and he's made it for everybody he's got
everybody enthused and interested and
that man is Jamie Oliver and it's
properly thrilling that today I'm going
to be cooking and eating and chatting
with my hero Jamie Oliver and he's so
important because what he's doing is
what we want to do he's democratizing
something that's absolutely essential to
a good life so here is my hero mate that
was the most incredible intro I wasn't
expecting that it's all true
genuinely I what you've done is
astonishing look at goosebumps now I'm
not sure I'm worthy of that but if you
are I better cut some bloomin good food
now done everything convinced me you can
do nothing wrong thank you
so Jamie the thing I really want to talk
to you about is how because we're all
about well-being and mental health is
that kind of food that will keep your
mind fresh active and you know keep
things in perspective that's the
challenge your body's basically like a
loofah right there's little kind of
caverns and pockets where it's just
sucking up all the things that it needs
some things it needs every day some
things that can hold on to and keep over
reserves for weeks and months I can show
you foods that are really rich and great
sources of things that particular your
brain likes the more you mix it up and
the more Whole Foods we mix up the more
chance you've got to be the very best we
can be
the obsession by one thing is going to
make you Clare
or fast I think we need to let go stay
away yeah I agree it's like in
philosophy people always say what's the
meaning of life it's like well life is a
you know made up of many many rivers
that flow into a central sea of meaning
it's not one thing but it's funny we
live in a culture where people do expect
one answer now philosopher Epicurus one
of the great philosophers of the ancient
world said the only things to feast on
that you need to be a king he said are
cheese and bread it reminds us that
human beings are not that complicated in
the end we just you know we need a few
basic things and we sometimes we think
we're just machines that we can never
understand some of these things are just
simple routes to happiness this is a
collection of things that you like this
is just a map of happiness colors look
great it's just it's healthful isn't it
should I tell you what we're going to
make please a la pesto tagliolini with
his favorite artichokes
and if you can just roll that lemon and
when you start to fill your hand
slipping a little yeah natural oils
coming out so we're going to go lemon
zest okay just a little you my bro
are gonna put the basil in here okay
grab the nuts and the cheese we're not
using palms then we're using Swiss
cheese why because he likes it where's
this up for whack oh stop
so now pour in there about five seconds
of olive oil to start off with garlic
goes in yeah and then we'll squeeze in
the juice of a quarter of a lemon give
it another little wet
[Applause]
we're such idiots for eating badly
aren't we
this is what you teach us what's
beautiful about this is a tablespoon is
all you need per portion we're now going
to add pasta this is tagliolini straight
into the pan is salted okay and we'll
just give it a little move around and
that will break up I'm going to do an
artichoke so there we go so much of it
is inedible and then the bit that isn't
is just great divine what I'm going to
do is slice in this thin
oh really does that then cook Wow wealth
and in harmony with the pasta Wow I'm in
awe
here is the artichoke and the
technically going in Wow
right and we're going to just toss it
around the water is going to Mull safai
with your Swiss cheese and it's going to
be sucked up even more so with the pasta
we're getting there we're getting this
is how I'm going to cook in the future
I'm so converted it smells divine
it looks amazing this food has got good
fats
it's got herbs it's got the goodness of
the nuts and the answer is there isn't a
golden bullet and that's not necessarily
a golden bullet but love care attention
will make you happy now I stressfully
wait over here for the verdict what I'm
loving is that all the different flavors
are coming out it's like listening to
music and all the notes are clear and
yet it's coming together in a wonderful
symphony I mean it it really is so me
it's like can I choice um yeah having a
very dying real food fresh food is the
best gift you can give to your mind body
and soul frankly you know will a
disaster to forget that actually you can
be happy on very little and this is the
proof of it and it's so simple it's
happiness is simple right with a little
knowledge so the question is you gave me
quite a tough brief yeah food to make
your mind work better
well definitely elements in here will do
that but more than that hopefully it
makes you feel good and there's goodness
in there and now in you so have I
answered your brief
you've answered it more than brilliantly
because I think what you've shown us is
that happiness is possible on first of
all a modest salary and with people who
had time short you can rustle this up in
minutes and it just it's like the food
of kings and queens that's available for
everyone so it's wonderfully democratic
and I think that's you know really very
much what we're trying to do at the
school of life which is to say there are
all sorts of arcane ideas stuck away in
the works of philosophers and great
writers that are normally people go all
you need tons of time and tons of money
and tons of whatever in order to unlock
them actually they're available you can
rustle them up in your own life and
that's why I've been always so
interested in Jamie and what he's up to
because he's democratizing something
very important which is you know the
food for your stomach and we're trying
to democratize
the food for your mind you know Jamie
and his team have been so generous to us
at the school of life please return the
favor and go and visit Jamie's a food
tube it's a wonderful place I've learned
so much there are recipes on all sorts
of things and you'll find something that
you love and learn to get your life in
shape with some truly fantastic recipes
and loads of other really passionate
cooks and share absolutely not just us
your team is your army and it's
brilliant
thanks guys lots of love Thanks we are
making a kind of Mexican ish breakfast
lovely silky omelette with cheese
gorgeous chili smashed avocado and
crispy little black beans it's gonna be
delicious
to help me I've got a special guest I'll
become John hey how are you doing John
really well really well how are you
enjoying the feast of all it's been
amazing as usual can we just pound up